there's nothing wrong with getting a
little Sun it helps stimulate vitamin D
production and even helps us sleep
better but too much time catching some
rays can earn you a nasty sunburn and
increase your risk of harmful conditions
like skin cancer so how do you measure
how much UV exposure you're getting
people typically use wearable devices
known as dosimeter x' to track how large
of a dose they're getting of the sun's
ultraviolet rays but these devices have
relied on straps or clips attached to
clothing and rechargeable battery packs
making them cumbersome and susceptible
to water damage now researchers have
developed a wireless battery free
dosimeter that can stick directly to
skin or fingernails and measure exposure
to UV rays in real time the chip is tiny
the diameter around half the size of the
dimes it uses a photodiode a kind of
semiconductor that converts light into
electricity to not only track how much
light it's been exposed to but also to
power the device the tiny chip also
includes a sensor to monitor the skin's
temperature circuitry to create a
measurement of cumulative exposure and
an antenna to wirelessly send the
results to the users smartphone to test
the technology researchers had
volunteers wear multiple chips on
different parts of their bodies while
spending the day participating in a
variety of outdoor activities such as
hiking and swimming they also wore a
larger traditional dosimeter for
comparison while a few of the chips fell
off during the course of the experiment
the ones that didn't perform just as
well as the regular dosimeter x' and
showed different parts of the body
received different amounts of sunlight
with the upper body absorbing the lion's
share of ambient radiation the chips
could one day be used in medical
applications the researchers also tested
their chips on the chests of infants
receiving therapeutic blue light
treatments for neonatal jaundice using
the chips to precisely monitor each
patient's dose in real time could lead
to tailored and potentially more
effective light treatments
these little Sun chips could also be
used in worker safety tracking exposure
to UV rays for welders and steel workers
researchers envision a future where
these handy dosimeter x' would be part
of everyone's daily wardrobe stuck
directly onto clothing sunglasses or
skin let you know when it's time to stay
off the sunny side of the street
[Music]